the moon is a giant rock that lights up
our night and can even change colors so
what would we do without it would we all
need night-vision goggles how would it
affect the ocean tides our seasons or
our sleep cycles or with the
consequences be far more dramatic this
is what if and here's what would happen
if we suddenly had no moon as the
closest celestial body to our planet the
moon exerts a gravitational pull that
governs much of what happens here on
earth take the sea for example if you
like surfing you can thank the moon when
the moon's gravitational pull tugs on
our spinning earth the oceans respond
giving us high tides in some parts of
the world and low tides elsewhere and
while the wind gives the waves their
energy tides define their shape the
moon's gravitational attraction also
keeps us at a stable 23.5 degrees tilt
relative to the Sun giving us four
seasons and a livable climate but what
if that livable climate were to suddenly
become unlivable with the moon gone its
stabilizing effect on the Earth's
rotation would go with it want the good
news first the weekend just got a whole
lot closer if the moon suddenly
disappeared a day on earth would only be
six to eight hours long over millions of
years shifting tides and their pressure
on the Earth's continents have slowed
our planets rotation giving us 24-hour
days but without the moon's strong
gravitational influence the world would
spend 3 to 4 times faster than it does
now here comes the bad news rotating at
that speed we would experience winds up
to 480 km/h birds and insects would have
no chance of survival the luckiest
land-based organisms would either be
deeply rooted plants or very short very
stout animals most of our marine life
would be wiped out since sea creatures
that rely on ocean currents for survival
would lose the privilege of the oceans
pole currents help circulate vital
nutrients from the ocean floor to the
surface while dragging oxygen-rich
surface water deep into the sea
we'd still have tides but now they'd be
governed by the Sun and from a distance
of 93 million miles away they'd only be
1/3 is powerful and with the moon
suddenly out of the way the oceans would
rip towards the Sun causing catastrophic
waves killing thousands and submerging
coastlines at this point we'd have to
adjust to new ocean currents which
circulating at a slower rate would be
heating up equatorial waters while
turning polar waters frigid these
extreme differences would produce a
similar effect on land as well since
ocean temperatures influence their
regional climates along with the Sun
Mars and other nearby planets could also
claim a share of gravitational influence
over our planet
pulling earth in different directions
and causing it to tilt with increased
volatility Earth's axial plane would
very some 10 degrees causing dramatic
shifts in seasons and rendering our
climate uninhabitable most crops would
die with the drastic temperature changes
we'd experience the worst ice ages known
to man as huge glaciers from the North
and South Poles would encroach upon the
earth covering everything except perhaps
a small band across the equator so while
full moons may attract werewolves that's
still better than an alternative world
where the moon doesn't exist
the next time you look up at the sky be
glad it's there sleep soundly tonight
Surf's Up in the morning